kennt der reife beschleuniger nicht s&t
aber in billiger salami traditionelle
metzger lassen salami fünf wochen reifen
viel zu lang findet sebastian lege er
verrät euch heute den reifen trick 48
stunden und dann ist die salami fix und
fertig egal ob discounter salami oder
markenprodukt viele hersteller tricksen
denn zeit ist geld lange reifezeit
machen ein produkt teuer also verkürzen
sie die mit zusatzstoffen unter den
namen reife kulturen oder starter
kulturen finden wir den zusatz bei
vielen salami produkten
daher kostet salami im supermarkt nur
fünf euro pro kilo
während man beim metzger locker mal 20
euro pro kilo zahlt sebastian lee
gelüftet den trick dahinter
zusammen mit metzgermeister peter in
hofen geht es jetzt um die wurst
traditionelle herstellung tritt an gegen
industrie trick peter wilhelm roos in
der salami bis sie bei mir auf dem boden
landet circa vier wochen
weil wir müssen erstmal das fleisch sein
und nach dem zerkleinern und wird zu und
so weiter leider war das halt stopp
zuviel arbeit sebastian kann es
schneller
und zwar mit cocoon delta lack toll oder
kurz gdl mit zusatz meines reife
beschleunigers brauchen wir nur 48
stunden und dann ist die salami fix und
fertig express reifung also aus fünf
wochen werden 48 stunden für unsere
gesundheit gilt das als unbedenklich
klar dass die industrie das zeug in
großen mengen einsetzt mehr wo es zum
weniger zeit ein knaller
und es wird noch besser wenn die wurst
schneller reift geht weniger wasser und
damit gewicht verloren
das spart 15 bis 20 prozent fleisch man
sieht jetzt schon eine kleine
farbveränderung meine dort wo auch jetzt
ungefähr um seine farbintensität zu
bekommen
mindestens vier von schulden okay ist
ein unterschied schon also das finde ich
beeindruckend wie schnell das gilt für
sebastians express salami geht es jetzt
48 stunden in die reife kammer der
traditionellen salami steht jetzt noch
wochenlanges trocknen bevor
wohingegen die express salami
[Musik]
eine waschechte salami die 98 prozent
zeitersparnis sieht man der wussten
nicht an kein unterschied zu fünf wochen
gerechten wurst aber wie schmeckt
die ist so soja lang und flach
langweilig sauer salzig vorne dein
produkt schmeckt wesentlich klarer muss
ich danke ja auf fünf wochen liebe
klar dass bei dem tempo der geschmack
leidet salami mit reife beschleuniger
schmeckt leicht säuerlich für uns der
hinweis dass da mit chemie nachgeholfen
wurde
ihr denkt das ist schon alles das pulver
kann noch viel mehr
es hilft auch käse beim reifen und wird
in vielen milchprodukten eingesetzt die
erst nach dem abfüllen fest werden
sollen es lässt teigwaren schön
gleichmäßig aufgeben und sogar ein obst-
und gemüsekonserven finden wir es dort
erhält es die farbe übrigens klug
weltall aktion wird nicht nur unter dem
namen reife kulturen angegeben wird es
als säuerungsmittel eingesetzt versteckt
es sich auch unter ii 575 lust auf noch
mehr tore schnelle tricks checks und
duell aus der welt der lebensmittel dann
ab auf unseren kanal zdf besser esser